president biden cracking down on guns as
america faces the impact of a historic
crime wave the president accused of
having misplaced priorities in going
after firearms and the second amendment
instead of focusing on putting criminals
behind bars the president announcing a
ban on so-called ghost gun kits which
are privately made firearms with
untraceable parts ordering his
department of justice to make it illegal
for a business to manufacture them
these guns are weapons of choice for
many criminals
we're going to do everything we can to
deprive them of that choice
and when we find them put them in jail
for a long long time
if you commit a crime with a ghost gun
expect federal prosecution i just say
expect federal prosecution this rule is
an important step it's going to sound
bizarre i support the second amendment
you have a right
but from the very beginning the second
amendment didn't say you can own any gun
you want as big as you want you couldn't
buy a cannon when in fact the second
amendment passed
and certain people from the very
beginning weren't allowed to purchase
guns
there's nothing new it's just rational
ban assault weapons and high capacity
magazines what the hell you need
20 bullets for you must be a hell of a
terrible shot there's nothing to do
with recreation
and speaking of bizarre check out this
moment the white house actually let the
president play with a gun
if you order a package like this one
over here
that includes the parts you need the
direction of assembling a functioning
firearm you bought a gun take a look
take a look at this comes in this
package
you can see the picture down here maybe
this is the gun
it's not hard
to put together
a little drill hand drill at home
it doesn't take very long
anyone
must come to you as your head your head
your hands head was in your hands as you
watched all that uh what do you think
about it especially the part of the
prosecution being federal you know what
the amazing part of it is there are very
few federal gun crime prosecutions the
feds are very particular about what
prosecutions they choose i know this
because i worked with them for 30 years
as a prosecutor and a d.a and i just
spent a couple of minutes on the phone
this afternoon with da's who still say
that the feds cherry-pick the crimes
that they want here's the bottom line i
have no problem with the president
saying we've got to prosecute these
crimes we absolutely have to prosecute
them ghost guns are outrageous there
shouldn't be any ghost guns but when
when the president talks about you know
stopping gun crimes it's not so much
about the gun it's about the criminal
who uses the gun it's about if you want
to stop gun crime you prosecute gun
crime and that means on the local level
and on the federal level that means when
you arrest them you keep them in jail
until they go to trial if they've got
any priors because they are a danger to
the community last week dana we spoke we
spoke about the sacramento case where my
friend the d.a anne marie schubert in
sacramento county said to the parole
board she said look this guy should not
be released he is a danger to the
community a 10-year sentence they let
him out in five or six years and he went
on to kill six people this is a problem
with the democrats they make it about
the weapon they don't make it about the
person and the the at the end of the day
the clearance rate by the feds is good
because they only take the good cases
but they're not making these arrests the
local police are making the arrest the
judges are not allowing or letting the
defendants out on bail where they're
committing more crimes more murders then
you've got prosecutors who are dropping
the gun component and charging them with
maybe assaults this is this is nothing
new why don't need that guy to get up
there and say we're gonna you're gonna
face federal prosecution that doesn't
scare anybody in background checks give
me a break joe how many criminals have
you prosecuted who went in to buy a gun
they buy these guns on the street they
don't go in for background checks and by
the way joe you have no credibility on
this your son's application for a weapon
included a lie perjury where he said he
didn't have a drug problem and he was
able to buy a gun so this isn't the guy
i want to listen to and to teach me how
to prosecute gun cases it's also about
the branding like ghost gun sounds scary
and it's like when they you would talk
about like an ar-15 like that
when you peel back the layers of the
marketing and the branding of it then
you realize what you have is a gun that
shouldn't be used in a crime anyway yes
it's guns
these have been around forever i mean
they're they're basically just guns with
obliterated serial numbers that's all
they are but they but they figure
ghost gun sounds really fancy and scary
and surreal oh we got to get rid of the
ghost guns they've been around forever
as the judge says it's not about it's
not about making new laws it's about
actually enforcing the laws there's a
weird thing where they democrats only
know step one we want more laws but step
two is okay enforce them not so fast i
gotta i gotta play golf but the problem
is obviously you lose the high ground
you have on gun control the moment you
allow for recidivist violent criminals
right if you let these people go back on
the streets while you also kind of
promote this anti-cop narrative that's
incompatible
with gun control
in a pro-criminal world you cannot tell
non-criminals that they can't protect
themselves i've said it before gun
control is dead after the two years of
the rioting and what we saw and how the
cops were treated ironically the
progressive cause of defunding the
police
might have been the most persuasive
argument for the second amendment right
the funding the police is almost
anarcho-capitalist in a way because as
an anarchist capitalist you would want
private security just like the squad has
so when you can see this is this is the
argument when you see the squad get
their protection needs while telling you
you can't have guns that makes you a
hypocrite harold what do you think about
all that i'm reminded first of all good
to be back i'm reminded of something
that jesse said last week uh-oh and i
agree with a lot that has already been
said jesse said we were looking at the
images in ukraine and we were being just
bombarded with death after death and the
the tragedy and the brutality he said we
don't get this upset at times when we
see this on our streets uh in in
big cities and small cities alike
you may have been motivated differently
to say that what i'm assigning
motivation for but i know our result how
we reacted to it was the same
this ghost gun issue i think is a bigger
issue
than we think especially when we talk
about gang bangers and communities
across the country where these kids
can't get these guns i hear you we hear
this and perhaps the terminology is
uh designed to incite
a bit but these are real issues that
cops are having to deal with
president biden i give him a lot of
credit today on this i've been critical
i've called balls and strikes on
democrats when it comes to crime in the
border uh he should have said something
about bell reform you've been the
biggest proponent of this an advocate on
this show for for repealing these laws
you've talked about reforming these laws
the president should use the bully
pulpit to ask prosecutors
and legislatures across the country to
reform bail laws as well because if you
remove and rid this rich streets of
ghost guns in neighborhoods and
communities where kids can't and you
didn't like when i says can't get a
fresh strawberry or a good book but
they're able to find a ghost gun you
said a fresh strawberry they could find
but if you can't find fresh fruit or a
good book but you can find a gun
something is wrong there we got to try
to fix that he wants more coordination
with the dea the atf i would encourage
congress democrats republicans to
confirm that former u.s attorney steve
dettelbach who's been who's been
appointed the uh atf director
let him go through a rigorous hearing
but let's get him on the job as quickly
as we can and then i think the president
ota said we ought to fund border patrol
and fund those who are at all of our
border points on the southern border
give our law enforcement every tool they
need to ensure that drugs that we're
we're trying our hardest to prevent
drugs from coming the country these
these gang bangers aren't protecting
neighborhood streets because they're
selling candy
they're protecting the streets because
they're selling guns and drugs so you
have to go out those things and the
president today i thought i gave him a b
plus a minus on the over his overall
effort but i give him an a for the
presentation day he's got to include
bell reform and he's got to include
drugs in the border and what he does
next
i mean he had the opportunity and he
didn't there are fruit trucks on every
block in this city
you can't avoid a fruit truck and they
have mountains of bananas and
strawberries some of the freshest spare
you've ever seen i was watching this
press conference that whatever the
president biden did today with jesse jr
and junior pops the pacifier out of his
mouth and says dad yes
joe biden is a ghost gun and i said well
what do you mean by that and he goes
well i never know where the guy's coming
from half the time
a pretty good one for junior good and
he's how old are you and he's and he
just turned one that is amazing he's
very perceptible
he talks to his dad talks well cracking
down on ghost guns is not going to
reduce crime at all over the last decade
only 2500 ghost guns were used in
criminal activity so you could ban every
single ghost gun right now and you
wouldn't drop the crime rate one percent
if i were a criminal and i was watching
the president today i'd say he has my
vote you want to know why what is the
one thing that criminals try to avoid at
all costs
jail
did he say anything about stiffer
sentences today nope no we didn't say
anything about that so if you're a
criminal you got to be thinking this is
the best president that we've ever had
never talks about that although he talks
about rehab he talks about summer jobs
programs if you're a gang banger you're
watching this you're like good got it
we're good so
the media and joe biden is actually
afraid to talk about gang violence drug
cartels they talk about gun violence and
it reminds me the way barack obama used
to talk about during the war on terror
he'd never say muslim
never say islamic terrorism because he
didn't want to offend anybody well who
is joe biden trying not to offend the
only thing i can think of he doesn't
want to offend black voters but if you
talk to black voters which i don't even
know if he does they want the criminals
off the streets more than joe biden does
so figure it out last point we had
johnny run numbers on federal gun
prosecutions obama had it here trump
comes in u.s attorneys actually
prosecuted more gun crimes on a federal
level and then joe comes in and they're
starting to drop off
is that it that's all i have for today
jesse junior have anything to say on
that last point no he will though
tomorrow because i was waiting for that
yeah it's going to be on special reports
coming up next the panel of a special
report just kidding coming up president
biden dragging down his entire party
after voters give him yet another brutal
midterm review